I find it fascinating that in a world
where so much is so new we welcome New
Years by singing a very old song
the chorus starts out for Auld Lang Syne
my Joe for Auld Lang Syne I'll take a
cup of kindness yet for Auld Lang Syne
Joe is a Scots word that can be
straightforward we translated to Deer
but Auld Lang Syne is more complicated
it literally means something like old
long since but it's idiomatically
similar to the old times we have a
phrase in English somewhat similar to
for Old Lang Syne the phrase is For Old
Times Sake
here's a bit of my old Wong sense
[Music]
in the summer of 2001 the writer Amy
Krauss Rosenthal emailed booklist
magazine to inquire about a review at
the time I was working for book list as
a publishing assistant most of my job
was data entry but I also answered many
of the low priority emails that came in
so I responded to Amy with an update on
the status of the review and I also
mentioned that on a personal note I had
loved her Zine like column in might
magazine I told her I often thought
about one bit she'd written which went
every time I'm flying and the captain
announces the beginning of our descent
the same thing goes through my mind
while we're still pretty high above the
city I'll think if the plane went down
now we would definitely not be okay A
bit lower and no we still wouldn't be
okay but as we get real close to the
ground I'll relax okay we're going off
now if it crashed now we might be okay
she wrote me back the next day and asked
if I was a writer and I said I was
trying to be and she asked if I had
anything that was two minutes long that
might work on the radio
foreign
[Music]
was written the first verse goes should
old acquaintance be forgot and never
brought to mind should old acquaintance
be forgot and Auld Lang Syne
versions of that date back at least 400
years but we owe the current song to The
Great Scottish poet Robert Burns in
December of 1788 he wrote to his friend
Francis Dunlop is not the scotch phrase
Auld Lang Syne exceedingly expressive
there's an old song In Tune which is
often thrilled through my soul light be
the turf on the breast of the
heaven-inspired poet who composed this
glorious fragment
and on the back of the letter Burns
wrote the first known draft of Auld Lang
Syne at least three of the verses were
probably his own although he would later
say of the song that he quote took it
down from an old man
part of what makes dating various Lines
within the song Difficult is the song's
eternality it's about drinking together
and remembering old times and almost
every idea within it from Picking
Daisies to wandering through fields to
toasting old friends over a beer could
have been written 500 a thousand or even
3 000 years ago it's also arousing Ode
to splitting the check incidentally with
part of the second verse going and
surely you'll buy your pint cup and
Shirley all by mine but mostly the song
is just an Unapologetic celebration of
the good old days and of looking back
upon them
I guess I should tell you that Amy is
dead
otherwise her death within this review
might seem like some kind of narrative
device which I don't want so okay
she is dead
the rare present tense sentence that
once it becomes true
stays true forever
but we aren't there yet we were still in
the past I think
she asked me if I had anything for the
radio and I sent her three little essays
and she liked one of them and asked me
to come in and record it for her show on
Chicago's public radio station WBEZ
in the broadcast you could hear the
nerves in my voice it was the first time
I'd ever reached such a large audience
after that Amy invited me to be on her
show more often and within a year I was
recording frequent commentaries for WBEZ
and then for NPR's All Things Considered
[Music]
sometimes Amy took me out to lunch
she was everything I wanted to be
happily married a committed and loving
parent and a successful writer
she was also incredibly good at gift
giving at her first lunch I told her
that when I moved to Chicago my mom
asked me to carry forty dollars with me
in my left pants pocket whenever I went
outside so I would have something to
give anyone who might want to mug me
and I told Amy that I still always kept
40 bucks in my left pocket and that I
tried never to spend my mugging money
except in cases of real need
the next time we met Amy surprised me
with two gifts one was a money clip
engraved with my initials jmg and the
other was a money clip engraved with mm
mugging money
in April of 2002 Amy convened some of
her writer and musician friends for an
event at the Chopin Theater in Chicago
called writer's block party she asked me
to read for it and I did and people
laughed at my dumb jokes and Amy hired
someone to walk around the theater
giving everyone compliments
and the complimenter said they liked my
shoes which were these brand new Adidas
sneakers and that is why I have worn
Adidas sneakers almost every day for the
last 17 years
Robert Burns originally had a different
tune in mind for Auld Lang Syne than the
one most of us know and although he
himself realized the air was quote
mediocre you will still sometimes hear
that original Arrangement it is used for
example in the noted 2008 film sex in
the city but the melody most of us know
first appeared in 1799 in George
Thompson's select songs of Scotland
by then Robert Burns was gone
he was only 37 when he died of a heart
condition possibly exacerbated by his
habit of raising many a pint glass to
Old acquaintances
in his last letter he wrote to Francis
Dunlop an illness which has long hung
about me in all probability will
speedily send me beyond that born whence
no traveler returns
but the song was just getting started
within decades it became a popular part
of New Year's Eve celebrations in
Scotland a holiday known as hogmanay
that can trace its history back to
Winter Solstice rituals by 1818
Beethoven had written an arrangement of
it and it was beginning to travel
throughout Europe and the
English-speaking world
today Auld Lang Syne is often played at
Japanese department stores just before
they close between 1945 and 1948 the
tune was used in South Korea's national
anthem in the Netherlands its Melody
inspired one of the country's most
famous football chants and it's a staple
of film soundtracks from Charlie
Chaplin's 1925 movie The Gold Rush to
It's a Wonderful Life in 1946 to minions
in 2015.
I think Auld Lang Syne is popular in
Hollywood not just because it's in the
public domain and therefore cheap but
also because it's the rare song that is
genuinely wistful it acknowledges human
longing without romanticizing it and it
captures how each new year is a product
of all the old ones
when I sing Old Lang Syne on New Year's
Eve I forget the words like everyone
does until I get to the fourth verse
which I do have memorized
we too have paddled in the stream from
Morning Sun till Dawn
but Seas between us broad have roared
since Auld Lang Syne
and I think about the many broad seas
that have roared between me and the past
Seas of neglect Seas of time
Seas of death
I'll never speak again to many of the
people who loved me into this moment
just as you will never speak to many of
the people who loved you into your now
and so we raise a glass to them and hope
that perhaps somewhere
they are raising a glass
to us
in her strange and beautiful interactive
Memoir textbook Amy Krauss Rosenthal Amy
wrote if one is generously contracted 80
years that amounts to 29 220 days on
Earth
playing that out how many times then
really do I get to look at a tree
twelve thousand three hundred ninety
five there has to be an exact number
let's just say it's 12
395. absolutely that is a lot but it is
not infinite and anything less than
infinite seems too measly a number and
is not satisfactory
in her writing Amy often sought to
reconcile the infinite nature of
Consciousness and love and yearning with
the finite nature of the universe and
all that inhabits it
toward the end of textbook she wrote a
multiple choice question
in the alley there is a bright pink
flower peeking out through the asphalt a
it looks like futility B it looks like
hope
for me at least Auld Lang Syne captures
exactly what it feels like to see a
bright pink flower peeking out through
the asphalt
and how it feels to know that you have
12
395 times to look at a tree
[Music]
in 2005 Amy published a memoir in the
form of an encyclopedia called
Encyclopedia of an ordinary life
that book ends I was here you see
I was
another sentence that once it becomes
true never stops being true
that book came out just a few months
before my first novel Looking for Alaska
soon thereafter my wife Sarah got into
graduate school at Columbia and so we
moved to New York Amy and I stayed in
touch and collaborated occasionally over
the next decade I played a bit part in
an experience she curated for hundreds
of people on August 8 2008 in Chicago's
Millennium Park
but it was never again like it had been
in those early days
she found out she had cancer not long
after finishing textbook Amy
crossrosenthal and she called me
she knew that in the years after the
Fault in Our Stars was published I'd
come to know many young people who were
Gravely ill and she wanted to know if I
had advice for her
I told her what I think is true that
love survives death
but she wanted to know how young people
react to death
how her kids would
she wanted to know if her kids and her
husband would be okay
or how she could make it okay for them
and that ripped me up
although I'm usually quite comfortable
talking with sick people
with my friend I found myself stumbling
over words
overwhelmed with my own sadness and
worry
they won't be okay of course
but they will go on
and the love you poured into them will
go on
that's what I should have said but what
I actually said while crying was how can
this be happening you do so much yoga
foreign
[Music]
people often have wonderful stories of
the horrible things that healthy people
say to them
but I've never heard of anybody saying
anything close to as stupid as you do so
much yoga
I hope that Amy got some narrative
mileage out of me saying something so
profoundly idiotic in her hour of need
but I also know I failed her
after she was there for me so many times
I know she forgives me
but still I desperately wish I could
have said something useful
or perhaps not said anything at all
when people we love are suffering
we want to make it better
but sometimes often in fact
you can't make it better
I'm reminded of something my supervisor
said to me when I was a student chaplain
at a children's hospital
don't just do something
stand there
Auld Lang Syne was a popular song in
World War One versions of it were sung
in trenches not just by British soldiers
but by French and German and Austrian
ones as well and the song even played a
small role in one of the strangest and
most beautiful moments in world history
the Christmas Truce of 1914.
on Christmas Eve that year in part of
the war's Western Front in what is now
Belgium around a hundred thousand
British and German soldiers emerged from
their trenches and met each other in the
so-called no man's land between their
front lines
one 19 year old British soldier wrote
his mother
yesterday the British and Germans met
and shook hands in the ground between
the trenches and exchanged souvenirs
marvelous isn't it
a German soldier remembered that a
British soldier quote brought a soccer
ball from their trenches and pretty soon
a lively game ensued how marvelously
wonderful yet how strange it was
Elsewhere on the front Captain sir
Edward Hulse recalled a Christmas
sing-along that quote ended up with Auld
Lang Syne which we all English Scots
Irish prussians wootenbergers Etc joined
in
it was absolutely astounding and if I
had seen it on cinematograph film I
should have sworn it was faked
Hulse who was 25 years old at the time
would be killed on the Western Front
less than four months later at least 17
million people would die as a direct
result of the war
more than half the current population of
Canada
by Christmas of 1916 soldiers didn't
want truces the devastating losses of
the war and the growing use of poison
gas had embittered the combatants
but many also had no idea why they were
fighting and dying for tiny patches of
ground so far from home and in the
British trenches soldiers began to sing
the tune of Auld Lang Syne with
different words
we're here because we're here because
we're here because we're here
was a world without wise where life was
meaninglessness all the way down
modernity had come to War and the rest
of Life the art critic Robert Hughes
once referred to the quote peculiarly
modernist hell of repetition
and the trenches of World War One were
hell indeed
[Music]
although she was a playful and
optimistic writer Amy was not deluded
about the nature of suffering or about
its centrality in human life
her work whether picture book or Memoir
always finds a way to acknowledge misery
without giving into it one of the last
lines she ever wrote was death maybe
knocking on my door but I'm not getting
out of this glorious bath to answer it
in her public appearances Amy would
sometimes use that recursive moment of
British soldiers and transform it
without ever changing the tune or the
words
she would ask an audience to sing that
song with her
we're here because we're here because
we're here because we're here
and although it is of course a
profoundly nihilistic song written about
the modernist hell of repetition
singing that song with Amy
I could always see the Hope in it
it became a statement that we are here
meaning that we are together and not
alone
and it's also a statement that we are
that we exist and it's a statement that
we are here that a series of astonishing
unlikelihoods has made us possible and
here possible
we might never know why we are here but
we can still Proclaim and hope that we
are here
I don't think such hope is foolish or
idealistic or misguided
I believe that hope is
for lack of a better word
true
we live in Hope that life will get
better and more importantly that it will
go on that Love Will Survive even though
we will not
as Emily Dickinson put it hope is the
thing with feathers that perches in the
soul and sings the tune without the
words and never stops at all
and we are here because we are here
because we're here
because we're here
sing it with me wherever you are
think of those across the broad and
roaring Seas
and sing with me
you won't be more off tune than I am
we're here because we're here because
we're here because we're here
we're here because we're here because
we're here
because we're here
[Music]